good morning belief nation today's
messages never give up over to you Jack
Canfield practice faithful persistence
means never ever ever give up Chicken
Soup for the Soul was rejected by a
hundred and forty four publishers 144
publisher said we don't want to publish
a collection of short stories the title
stupid Chicken Soup for the Soul what
does that mean people don't buy
collections of short stories there's
never been you know successful chain of
doing that so literally we spent 14
months trying to find a publisher and
we'd go to New York with our agent and
eventually our agent gave us the book
back and said I can't sell this so we
went to the National booksellers
Association convention down in Anaheim
we went from booth to booth to booth for
three days and there were 4,000
publishers represented there and we go
would you publish a book would you
publish a book would you publish my book
and we got no no no no no it was late on
the third day that a little publisher
from Florida after we'd gotten over 144
rejections said we'll read it and then
they said we said well how many copies
do you think we'll sell after they said
yeah we'll buy it a couple weeks later
said we'll publish it and we said they
said well maybe 20,000 if we're lucky
and we said we our goal is to sell a
million and a half in a year and a half
now have you ever told someone your
dream and had them laugh out loud here
he laughed out loud now if we had given
up after a hundred publishers had said
no I wouldn't be standing here today
you know wouldn't have happened and so
you've got to be willing to persevere
because we didn't take no see when the
world says no you say next let's
practice that if I say no you say
absolutely there's only five or six
billion people out there you can go and
ask right there's over four thousand
publishers just here in the state of
California so what we have is this
endless possibility but you have to
persevere it's as if the universe tests
our commitment and so today we have 147
titles in print we sold over 115 million
copies
we're in 47 languages and over a billion
dollars where the Chicken Soup for the
Soul books have been sold worldwide so
if you're willing to decide what you
want believe it's possible consciously
envision the future feel the feelings of
what it would feel like if you'd achieve
this goal you can have anything and then
you take action both obvious actions and
inspired actions you can do anything I
love this message and I agree that the
reasons to give up aren't because you
don't have the resources you don't give
up because you don't have resources you
don't give up because somebody told you
no you don't give up because somebody
laughed at your dream you don't give up
because you're afraid you don't give up
because you feel you don't have the
education you don't give up for all the
excuses that are in your head the reason
why you would give up though would be
you don't love what you're doing anymore
or maybe you never loved it in the first
place or maybe you don't believe in it
anymore for me that's when you give up
and you move on to something else
because you're doing something that you
don't believe in or that you don't love
there's no way that that's the best use
of your time you need to focus your time
on the things that make you come alive
and where you can have a big impact on
the world
but just make sure if you're thinking
about giving up you're doing it for the
right reasons not because you're afraid
so when you early years in my
entrepreneurship career when I was
thinking about giving up I did two
things that really helped me stay
focused the first is the why why am I
doing this why is it so important think
about it for yourself if you're feeling
down right now why are you doing this
business why is it so important to you
that this succeeds what's the impact
that you want to have if you do not have
a strong why then your business is dead
in the water so make sure you
send yourself around that every time you
feeling low the second thing is it was
surround myself with entrepreneurial
mentors who I looked up to and looked at
their early years look at their early
stories because any successful
entrepreneur that you would look up to
they had they struggled early on it
wasn't just handed to them they had
setbacks they had failures they probably
started with less than what you already
have right now and just realizing that
gave me the motivation to keep going
that if Bill Gates could do this if
Oprah Winfrey could do this if Steve
Jobs could do this and if these people
who didn't have a lot could go and make
something of themselves and become
massively successful then I can do it
too
so remembering the why I'm focusing on
success stories that really with
motivation on a daily basis I found
helped me stay motivated but it's got to
be something that you still believe in
and don't give up because you're afraid
so the question day today is when did
you consider giving up what are the
reasons behind it going a little deep
little personal leaving comments below
I'm going to join the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to
William Chilton William thank you so
much for buying a copy my book really
means a lot to me
those are you watching if you want to
change that a shadow in a future video
make sure to grab a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day you seem to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso
you